these official it is official Barack is
a supervillain that's what everyone's
favorite mannchild superhero is gonna be
fighting everyone's favorite manchild
superhero The Rock is Black Adam now
we've known he's gonna be in this Shazam
movie for a while because we're not
idiots big thing was is he gonna be
black Adam the villain or Shazam the
hero and he's going to be black Adam the
villain now am i myself I thought he
would have been perfect a Shazam that's
not to say he's not gonna kick ass his
block at him because he is I think is
gonna be a badass black Adam he's gonna
be going up against Shazam kicking his
ass but there is a part of me it's like
I would have liked to say it was a big
manchild dale's Shazam simply because
when you look at the guy but look at
that mug look at that smile how do you
not see just a big happy dude like I'm
actually 14 in here I mean that the most
complimentary way possible for those of
you who don't know Shazam the hero was
Billy Batson he's this kid then he finds
us wizardess wizards like I'm gonna give
you the power of Shazam all you need to
do is say Shazam and a lightning bolt
hits him and now he's an adult superhero
but he's still look you know the kid
mentally however the wizard made a
mistake at one point and gave Black Adam
that power and now black Adams just this
big douchebag not always a douchebag
though that's what I like about this
that they can do black Adam one of a few
different ways I do not want them to
make it black and white like no block
Adams just a big he's just mean
he's going after Shazam because for the
rock to play a villain like that I'm
gonna be like that's just a big waste
yeah Black Adam is a conqueror he's a
dictator he's essentially trying to kill
a kid but I want him to have at least
one bit of dialogue where he's like my
world has zero crime on it can you say
that and you and Superman say that sure
then he can reference some Batman V
Superman stuff be like no you can't
gotta save all the goings on and the DC
castings that they have done this is the
one I'm most fine with and the rocks
established he's an actor he's more than
a wrestler at this point I can say that
oh yeah you were it although I still
call you the rock I will call him the
rock for most of this video but he's not
there he's Dwayne Johnson but he used
wrestling as a means to get into acting
and now he's done that now he's
established I can't say that for a lot
of people who try that same thing and on
that I really helps you Sam isn't
another wrestler out there I don't want
to see the rock and John Cena fighting
on-screen the good thing about this is
black Adam you know he's the villain you
want him to be bigger than Shazam so
she's an thing is he goes from a
kid to an adult so the adult Shazam the
hero doesn't have to be as big as the
rock yeah he has the same essential
powers of Superman so in that he's going
to be big but I'm just
he doesn't have to be that big in fact I
prefer him to be smaller wouldn't that
be awesome less his damn goes face to
face with Black Adam he's like I'm sure
Sam and black Adams Oh like fruit turns
it's all huge you sure you like the
almost here Shazam 'like later so
although i personally was hoping that
the rock would have been Shazam because
I like that mannchild smile that
likability that the rock hasn't I think
he'll kick-ass his block out I'm gonna
admit when I was like oh the rockers
Shazam who would they help me Billy
Batson and then I saw it in my head you
me Black Adam it's fine so the rock as
black a diminishes a movie what do you
think about that and who do you think
they should have plays Shazam whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more